I'm Karen Lightman I'm executive
director of Metro 21 smart cities
Institute here at Carnegie Mellon
University we are a strong partner of
the Wilson East Scott Institute and
we're really excited to be here a part
of energy Week and it's my honor and
delight to be introducing this panel
let's see our tie our panel that's
coming up is managing energy and water
infrastructure and I'm excited to be
introducing the folks to my left
including Peter frisk who's gonna be
today Fisk rather who's going to be
today's moderator peter is the director
of water and energy resilience Research
Institute at the Lawrence Berkeley
National Laboratories he is the director
of wer RI and his goal is to orient and
align the water related research
programs to address critical gaps in
reliability efficiency sustainability of
watered watered energy systems in
California as well as the country then
to his left is Herve Busan I think I got
it right right we rehearse this he's
vice president and process engineering
at Veolia water solutions and
technologies since 2005 Herve has served
as the vice president of process
engineering solutions of technologies
and he's a member of the executive
committee of the company and then to his
left is Megan mount mater that rhymes
with water
she's associate professor civil and
environmental engineering and public
policy here at Carnegie Mellon
University Megan's research probes
pathways for meeting water demand in a
carbon-constrained world by optimizing
policies evaluating efficiency and
developing and modeling materials to
maximize performance and then to her
right is Venky Sharma he's the president
and CEO of aqua tech Venky has been at
the helm of aqua tech for more than 20
years so no longer a start-up right
and he's transforming it from a small
regional manufacturer of industrial
water treatment equipment to a leader in
global water industry with a focus on
solving water scarcity issues please
join me in welcoming the panel and Peter
take it away thanks very much for coming
out today right when we were off stage l
vey you said that you've been in R&D in
water for essentially your whole career
but you said now was one of the most
exciting times to be in water tell us
why yes so I was in Canada in our indeed
and in France I was heading the R&D
center for our company and I came to the
US and I am an R&D guy in which some
time I busted your two R&D I can assure
you that I have seen a lot of
innovations but what I see today is the
background innovations in material
sciences biotechnology Computer Sciences
digital Sciences is so exciting because
we have a lot of things that our
industry will be able to use in the
future so when I see young kids in
university is not I really tell them you
are lucky because you can have very
interesting bright future and the water
is no longer considered you know a small
thing every industry seeing water are
strategic so it's a fantastic time and
thinkI you now lead a company that is
innovating in the water space I noticed
in our our previous title it was titled
managing energy and water infrastructure
but it said managing energy comma and
water infrastructure so why don't you
tell us a little bit about where you see
the emerging connections between water
and energy in particular with with in
Pennsylvania it's my Mike working yes I
think that energy and water historically
and more so today are very intertwined
and we call it the energy water Nexus
energy requires lots of water and
treating water whether it's for air
pollution whether it's for high purity
requires lots
energy in Marcellus Shale as an example
in Pennsylvania energy extraction for
shale gas shale oil requires tremendous
management of water whether it be for
treating and for the reuse of frack
water or production brines which
ultimately our end of life type water
and so there's a lot of recycle and
reuse treatment and there's a lot of
ultimately more advanced technology
treatment emerging as a area and a mark
you know I don't like to call you can't
generate generalize Marcellus Shale you
really have micro markets that develop
based on where the concentration of TDS
is in a market why don't once you define
well I was gonna say TDS is total
dissolved or dissolved solids in other
words the amount of salt and dissolve
things right so typically you know
southwestern Pennsylvania will have an
average total dissolved solids level at
Lava average distance from disposal and
it'll have average water availability in
depending on all of those things the
need for advanced technology will will
happen you know the amount of brine so
in other words you have different
flavors of water even across a single
producing area call them micro mark
micro markets Micro and and then
different environments around the United
States will have different flavors of
water as well absolutely I mean if
you're in the Permian Basin it's a water
scarcity driven market in Pennsylvania
we're typically a disposal driven market
or lack of disposal so in power oil and
gas is largely the same and electron is
the same no matter where you go but in
water things are very different Megan in
Pennsylvania what challenges do you see
that that gives for water infrastructure
if the conditions and the chemistry's of
water can be so variable it's okay
and as thank you is alluding to in in
the produced water treatment space
especially there is quite a bit of
variability both spatially but also
temporally and which means that your
treatment technologies need to respond
to very very different total dissolved
solids concentrations over the lifespan
of the well Megan why don't you explain
a little bit about because our audience
is familiar with what happens when
you're at the various stages in oil and
gas what types of water go in and how do
they come out and how do they change
just briefly yeah sure so when you are
injecting your frack fluid and that may
be a freshwater source that's being used
to suspend the profit and the chemicals
that are used in the hydraulic
fracturing operation or some of that
water may actually be recycled so we'll
come back to that in just a second
you also have formation water or water
that is present in the shale itself and
so after the fracturing operation
actually happens you get flowback water
the composition of which looks something
like the composition of the water that
you put down the well in the first place
and then over time it evolved to look
much more like the water that's present
in the formation itself these shales
have a number of different minerals that
that make up the rock including large
concentrations of clay sometimes which
have lots and lots of ions in sort of
trapped in that clay layer and that is
most likely the source of a lot of the
high concentration dissolved solids that
we see in the flowback water here in the
Marcellus it sounds like a terrible
treatment challenge and in some respects
is is this putting new demands on the
technology for water treatment eleve as
leader in R&D in one of the largest and
most sophisticated water technology
companies in the world how is that
challenging the traditional water
treatment systems yeah I think you know
what we have best available technologies
have been established and so for a long
time but when we treat this type of new
waters which change like you were saying
Megan definitely you really need
you rethink your your standard offering
you need to optimize it you need to
tweak it what the customers want what
the industry want is resilience
reliability you know every day the plan
is not running is it's very important so
I think the way you design a plan for
this type of application in Pasadena is
different from what we've been using to
do in other places and truly we are
learning also every day as you get
confronted with the industry you know
how to optimize this train yeah you see
a lot of two types of technologies I'll
stop there but you have technologies
that are implemented at the early stage
of fracking which is very dispersed
small mobile units you know that's gonna
go and then at some point when you start
to do more and more and you have more
flow then you're gonna start to see
bigger plants and the technologies we
use our state-of-the-art technology will
unit evaporation membranes I mean those
are complex so so one of the things that
a lot of people might not realize is
that the volumes of water relative to
the hydrocarbons you get I'm trained as
a geologist but even I was surprised by
the volume of water relative to oil that
comes out of the ground even in a
quote-unquote normal well so many oil
and gas companies really are in the
water business whether they like it or
not
Venki um have you seen innovation from
the oil and gas industry with respect to
how they treat their water or are they
relying on us to solve all these
problems for them oil and gas producers
are demanding innovation from ourselves
field and other players in the market
they're in demanding technology
innovation they're demanding business
model innovation
herve referred to mobility taking
technology into mobile assets have big
has become an important aspect one of
the things as far as customers
innovating themselves to your question
Peter they have you know what we see
emerging is really depending on the
recipe that a and this becomes fairly
complex for a producer because he's
thinking about how often he's going to
have to restate and
the the well as well as his yields and
the more sophisticated producers are
really demanding designer water what we
call designer water a very specific
recipe and that's part of the innovation
that's going on and that's demanding
technology innovation from ourselves and
others so you have to sort of become the
barista from hell you've got an infinite
variety of water coming in and you've
got to make an infinite variety of
different flavored drinks going out keep
in mind most of the water we deal with
is three or four times more concentrated
than seawater so sea water is is
typically around 35,000 TDS total
dissolved solids we're dealing with one
hundred and forty thousand on average
TDS so it's totally different than the
industrial the worse than the dead
survey and we are used to yeah and you
have to purify that you have to purify
that to drinking water standards that
sounds like a very complicated and and
and and perhaps insurmountable to house
come is drinking water to standards
because of the technologies deployed
membranes evaporation eventually yield
drinking water standards you don't think
the producers don't require it it's an
outcome of what processes are demanded
by the situation so wait a minute so we
don't necessarily need to treat to a
drinking water standard if your disposal
if you're discharging you might you
might yes okay um Megan this issue of
treating two different levels how does
that pose challenges and opportunities
for Rd and and what new what new
exciting frontiers do you see emerging
from the science side of things yeah so
I think that the first frontier is
actually avoiding treatment altogether
or minimizing treatment treatment is
very very costly it's also energy
intensive and it's hard to do and the
distributed scale that's relevant to
most of these oil and gas operations in
a place like Pennsylvania and so the
first innovation is really in being able
to reuse that flowback water despite its
high concentration of TDS there's been a
lot of innovation in the formulations
that companies have used
and we've moved from jelf racks which
require low divalent ion concentrations
now that's a lot of thethat's a lot of
technical speak so GL fracked are you
saying you put jelly in the ground
it's a cross-linked polymer that's oh
that's much better Thank You Maegan the
first innovation is really in moving
towards water reuse operations there's
also been a lot of innovation in how you
treat a high salinity brine so our lab
is doing some work in I'm using low
temperature heat to drive membrane
distillation processes we're doing some
work in how to use existing reverse
osmosis membrane equipment in new
configurations to be able to push the
upper limit of that total dissolve
concentration solid concentration beyond
where reverse osmosis currently works
and then finally I think that there's a
lot of opportunity still yet to be
tapped in really understanding how to
recover some value from these brines
and there are colleagues that I have in
the civil environmental engineering
department and that are doing quite a
bit of work in warth element recovery
from those brights eleve Veolia is an
international company and now we're
talking specifically about some of the
challenges and opportunities of dealing
with water in the energy sector in the
United States can you look at other
countries as Veolia working elsewhere in
the world and are you seeing some
interesting examples or lessons that can
be informing United States or are we
really on the forefront of dealing with
some of these challenges yeah I mean
there is a lot of it depends the scope
you take I mean if you take shale gas
definitely I think here is at the front
of what's happening large to wet gas and
then you are not and then we have seen
we've seen projects in the world we have
seen very interesting projects they are
all very different the regulations are
different the but the funny thing is the
technologies base is similar but to make
the process resilient you know small
changes are very very
important I think for me the keys so we
are in the world there is a lot
demanding yeah there is a lot of
interesting projects worldwide we are
also working a lot in the power industry
in general you know power plants so we
could enlarge it a little bit but for
shale gas I mean here is is really yeah
ok you you bring up the the point that
water and energy are interconnected
through cross number of sectors not just
oil and gas and in fact in the United
States one of the biggest revelations
was when droughts come oftentimes power
plants are not able to operate at peak
capacity because they utilize just the
existing river water which may end up
really flowing at a much lower level
yeah New Mexico you know right now at
the u.s. is amazing so I come from North
Carolina as you can tell for myself I
your excel that's right there the
problem is too much water in too short
time you know when we have but then you
know New Mexico and so I think in the
u.s. you have this amazing problems
linked to water sometimes not enough
sometimes too much
definitely a VPP yeah talk to Houston
about too much water it can happen Vicki
it has been said that the water industry
is very slow-moving and not terribly
innovative and yet you've been you're
leading a company that is in this space
do you is it personal is that a fair
statement or is it not quite true and if
it is true how does a technology
innovator be effective if the
environment is slow-moving
I think that in general that the water
industry is has that historical brand of
being slow moving on technology I think
ultimately we're driven by our customers
demands we have kind of three mega
trends that are going on one is water
scarcity that's been increasing that's
driving innovation we have regulation
and then we have ultimately higher
purity demands from processes
that are driving innovation demand so
more than ever today as irv a referred
to I would say we're in the golden age
of water technology and areas such as
electrochemistry area such as material
science area such as membranes bio tech
digitization automation chemistry all
converge into solutions because all of
these require solutions and kind of I
touched on automation but today we have
the issue of how we can drive automation
towards optimization and robustness and
delivering performance these are
frontiers and water that exists so I
think today like no other is the
frontier of it's a golden age for water
that's great and and Megan are you
seeing that from undergraduates at CMU
or is the message not out yet do you
have a line around the around the
hallway outside your office seeking to
become majors in your discipline well I
see that caval is here instead of being
at class but it's great to see you give
out uh-huh I do see a lot of excitement
and particularly among students that
that are interested in engaging in the
research space so I think that as more
and more undergraduates come in with
interest in in the water space finding
ways to link that research to companies
and and to provide a path forward for
them to continue innovating in their
professional careers is really important
mm-hmm thank you
here people on this panel may are
probably well aware and maybe some of
you in the audience that Cape Town South
Africa is facing a dire crisis with
respect to water supply and I'm curious
for each of you to share with us first
of all we all in the water industry know
this issue but what do you think the
lessons are for Cape Town situation and
you know just wanted to sort of pass
that question every when I say Cape Town
you say what beautiful city yes it is
no I think planning is very important
you know water should not be taken for
granted we need to look at data we need
to plan and we need to understand in the
case of Cape Town you know they have
planned see you cannot plan everything
you know sometimes Australia built an
incredible capacity of design nation
plans which was good for an industry and
suddenly started to rain a lot as if
that's right it was as if they made a
big pile of money on the beach and it
set it on fire the rains came from the
sky so that's a bad example
so but I think we really need to plan to
think I think also what's important
Singh energy don't sing on your water it
costs a lot of energy to desalinate sea
water
so what about the reuse I think we you
should be definitely a big part of the
city thinking because reuse is cheaper
in terms of energy it has less you know
easier you know way cheaper so so I
think some of our cities have not
planned enough in the u.s. we know that
in terms of water infrastructure
unfortunately there hasn't been enough
renewal so the underground
infrastructure which is in other pipes
the are totally some of them are need
change and the budget needed to really
upgrade that is is very is a very big
budget so and then think innovative
don't think they like the old ways do we
need this mega centralized structures or
do we need more decentralization and
then dispersal I mean all that needs to
be carefully everything yeah okay Megan
I say Cape Town you say I say that we
really need to think about resiliency
and diversification this is a term that
Herve used earlier but resiliency
incorporates tapping a number of
different sources whether that's
groundwater whether that surface water
reservoirs whether that's water reuse or
whether that's water desalination
particularly in a changing climate when
we don't know exactly how precipitation
is likely to change over the next 50 to
100 we're likely to need to have a wide
portfolio of water supply options to be
able to ensure resilience
to that changing climate I say Cape Town
Venky you say Singapore tell us more I
say prevention through strategies
similar to what's in Singapore is
undertaken because they've taken up a
multi-tap you know this is a island
country that should have only focused on
desalination they focused on everything
possible on water and energy efficiency
innovation they're constantly threatened
by Malaysia of shutting down the tap so
you know they're a very they've they set
out a very compelling blueprint for
planning and it's a mix of trying to
drive down the cost of desalination
through power reduction it's through
it's things like me water where we
change our thinking we're we know what's
that term again new water and like right
here new water yes no no Kay but
basically it's taking recycled water
whether it's industrial sewage or others
and recycling it and you know
understanding that water is water and if
it's chemically clear and drinkable then
you do it so so Singapore has actually
pioneered direct potable reuse that's
right do you think that that is
something that the US could effectively
manage or even emotionally except we may
not be that may be an eventual tap we'd
we may not need to do that any time soon
there are so many other things
industrial reuse other forms of reuse
and it's you know the first two issues
are really about optimizing reuse in the
use of desalination and then continuing
down other paths
Singapore has been more aggressive we
can do it there's no reason we shouldn't
do meagan some people complain that that
some of these water solutions like
desalination are just enormous Lee
energy-intensive and they have their own
carbon footprint associated with them
some people suggest that really a lot of
our needs could be addressed simply
by conservation do you think
conservation is is is largely an answer
do you think they're there what's the
point of no-return with conservation
yeah so I want to point out that there's
not just a carbon footprint but there's
also air mission externalities
associated with this electricity
consumption as well as chemical
consumption so we've done a lot of work
to try to quantify that and in many
cases we find that these air mission
externalities are even larger than the
public health benefits of treating some
of these water sources
so really the smog is worse than the
harmful smog is worse diffic
applications and some specific required
best availment that's the best available
treatment technologies and there can be
some real trade-offs in the air emission
externalities associated with water
treatment especially if we're using very
energy intensive water treatment
processes like mechanical vapor
recompression and crystallization where
you're taking water and you're basically
evaporating all that water and making a
pure salt so we do need to think about
what those trade-offs are and I think
that doing so in a quantitative manner
helps us to make wise decisions I also
think that much like in the energy
efficiency space thinking about water
efficiency is likely to be the lowest
cost and and certainly the least
impactful opportunity well the the most
the least environmentally impactful
opportunity for reducing the energy
intensity of water treatment and of
water supply that conservation can come
through retrofitting of our
infrastructure systems for water
delivery it's also already happened
quite a bit through innovation in our
appliances but there's a number of
existing opportunities to think about
conservation and and water recycling
that that still need a lot of work ok
Veolia runs a number of water utilities
even at the national level in some
countries in in the energy sector we've
often struggled to have our power
suppliers accept and embrace energy
conservation because it simply means
less revenue
or the power producer and they're stuck
with the same amount of infrastructure
and less revenue for their
infrastructure did the same situations
apply for water utilities and if so are
there any clever solutions to solving
that problem so there's two models in
what our utilities there is one where
the Ute doesn't own the assets so
basically the utility is just an
operator of the asset that's typically
what we do in many many cases so in that
case the revenue I guess you will always
probably have a biased like you
mentioned so yes we are but I think in
that case there is also an incentive
sometimes in different cities would
incentivize consumption I think it's
very important to really look at at this
upstream reduction of usage and then the
second second model is okay then we also
are a capital investor in the project so
but that's not what the companies like
ourselves would do but there is also
private utilities which also basically
put the money and only the assets and I
guess but but you know what the utility
is I mean it's again a partnership with
local cities with a region to define an
agenda at a certain scale and then you
push that agenda in and the water
utility is part of that agenda and then
so conservation just becomes one of the
elements in water strategy yeah that is
defined on a higher level and a basin
level maybe on a water basin level and
then you basically abide by certain
guidelines and you have certain
incentives to you know to minimize that
your consumption yeah great I'm gonna
encourage audience members to send in
some questions we've already gotten some
wonderful questions here and here's one
that I I like a lot the audience member
asks oh what about the use of
desalination plants as a flexible load
so how can water treatment be actually
used collaboratively with energy
generation and energy supply Megan do
you have any thoughts on that
graduate students to answer this
question but he might have been the one
asking the question in are now yes so so
I think that there are some trade-offs
these are typically pretty capital
intensive treatment plants and so you
don't want to over build water treatment
capacity and if you are concerned about
you know if you're gonna be operating a
capacity factor for your water treatment
facility that's only twenty percent but
you still need to supply your municipal
water you know your miscible water needs
you're not going to upsize that plant by
five times so you need to think about
what are the trade-offs and capital
costs and operational costs making this
a somewhat difficult play for a
desalination plant and we're doing some
some work right now particularly in
distribution systems to understand what
sort of capacity there is to shift the
load for pumping and what implications
that might have for water quality in the
distribution system as well and then I
think the other the other piece that is
is really important to think about is
smaller scale more distributed systems
and particularly that have intermittent
treatment needs and in those situations
I think that there's a lot more
potential for either load balancing or
use of intermittent renewable resources
to help power some of those water
treatment technologies thank you I want
to comment on that sure you know there's
there's tremendous opportunity in hybrid
desalination which involves you know the
to the leading technology is membrane
based he foundation but you know there
are opportunities to hybridize them with
thermal desalination where you optimize
waste heat from an off taker
we believe that solar is going to play a
very important role in the future and
driving down
because desalination or desalination
plants are usually in Sun rich areas and
those are there's there's an array of
things and with automation the ability
to optimize and balance things it's a
whole new frontier so there's a lot of
opportunities but as I said recycling
water and desalination is really the
solution but desalination has tremendous
scope for optimization they you know
Veolia do you also run power facilities
yeah we're not no power facilities we
run power systems like cooling cooling
district cooling district heating yeah I
have two interesting examples one from a
Swiss friend who tells me you know we
have got you good you guys because what
they do very interesting you know that
the power plant you know has excess
capacity at night depending how power is
produced with nuclear you don't want to
go up and down so what they have done is
fantastic they put the cheap power at
night you know what they do with it they
pump water at night they bring water up
the Alps at night and then they resell
the electricity when it's high and it's
hydroelectric power so this type of
thing is possible we also had a project
where we are looking at a power plant
also having excess capacity at night and
then we costed a desalination plant to
do a storage because storage of energy
is the big issue right energy story at
the end of that is all about energy
storage so can you use water to store
energy and how do you do that so one way
is the Swiss Way pump up but then we are
looking at this Allan 18 water during
night and then doing what is called
aquifer storage and recovery so you take
this on United Water put it in the
aquifer and then you know your basic
that's energy that you have saved and
then so the our project is not so many
but it's it's gonna happen more and more
so wait a minute so you could you could
go to this how is it Mount Washington
here you could potentially put a tank at
the top of the hill and and pump water
up from the river in the middle of the
night and then so these times I suppose
be small there he lies to be steep you
know there are some conditions but yeah
you can they got some steep hills here I
think so
turning now towards maybe closer issues
city of Pittsburgh I'm familiar with
with their water system it was one of
the water systems that my company dealt
with and city of Pittsburgh has had a
range of challenges over the years with
with treating and preventing water one
was led a number of the components of
the distribution system in Pittsburgh
have led and Ave Veolia has has been in
operations with respect to Pittsburgh
what have what have we learned both from
the specific challenges with managing
Pittsburgh systems and what do we learn
in general about older municipal water
distribution systems so I am in a global
industrial division so I have to admit I
know very little about the specific here
and I am NOT well-placed to talk about
it more on the complex industrial
projects but I think what we learn all
is water chemistry is very important and
so in utilities you know we need to pay
a lot of attention to that chemistry I
mean as the infrastructure you know is
aging we have concrete we have some
metals we have some and we had we had a
chemistry that was optimized for that
anyway I'm talking in industries the
same corrosion is a big deal and so we
have to really pay attention to to that
but again I cannot comment about because
I have I am NOT it's a different
division in operation who was involved
in that short act so I really yeah
I really am not sure well another area
that affected Pittsburgh was issues
related to the discharge of treated
water from the oil and gas industry
Megan what were some of the issues that
Pittsburgh encountered there and what
were their solutions I have a colleague
Jean vamp reason in civil environmental
engineering who's done a lot of work on
understanding the impacts of bromide
discharges on the formation of
disinfection by-products and drinking
water treatment plants and there if you
have high concentrations of chlorides
and bromides it can accelerate and
enhance the formation of chlorinated or
Roman ated organics
during the drinking water treatment
process so in other words that the same
stuff that we use to disinfect the water
to make it clean and safe for us to
drink also has the potential for
unintended consequences with formation
of byproducts that's correct
and we have disinfection by-product
regulations in place to make sure that
those concentrations are at levels that
minimize the risks to public health
while still ensuring that you're getting
water that does not have lots of
bacteria or virus in it but modulating
and ensuring that you're in compliance
with that regulation and can be tough
when we have low River flow conditions
so in the summertime when it's dry and
or when there's a large amount of either
cooling water from power plants or oil
and gas discharge water both of which
are high in these chlorides and bromides
so we all share the same water and
whether we like it or not water and
energy inextricably linked binkey the
oil and gas sector has sometimes been
criticized about their treatment of
water and some people suggested that
there really is no that that water and
oil don't mix you know that there is no
conceivable way in the long run for the
oil and gas sector not to damage our
water sector you're in the water
treatment business for the sector what
are your thoughts well I think those
comments are usually not well-founded on
facts the technology does exist to be
able to support full environmental
stewardship and and I think that
producers typically want to meet
environmental stewardship standards so I
think everything's there to do it I do
agree with Megan and that's what's going
on in the in most of the plays is that
maximizing recycle at this point or
reuse of water is happening and as they
progress as ever they mentioned you'll
continue on a continuum
technology needs that will be supported
with more and more advanced technologies
especially as fields become mature so
yeah so so it is it is well within our
means to effectively treat water some
people have been concerned about the
contamination of drinking water aquifers
from produced water is that a serious
issue in Pennsylvania you know I don't
think so
I mean I think that responsible
treatment is out there it's well
regulated well another factor is that
sometimes oil and gas is produced at a
far deeper level and the earth than the
than the aquifer is where did we draw
our drinking water so there's actually
some physical separation in some cases
looking ahead there's a lot of
innovation in artificial intelligence
machine learning how do you think that
those technologies are going to affect
how we design water infrastructure and
operate water treatment systems oh they
don't okay we can raise our hands a lot
have you seen some creative examples
already or any surprises that you've
seen in how those technologies can and
cannot affect water treatment yeah I am
making a presentation on that in Asia in
a couple of weeks I think definitely a
lot we will need sensors we are going to
need reliable sensors because data is
based on the EM information so we have
some sensors but we need more sensors
reliable we have seen drones yeah there
will be a lot what is it gonna be the
industry is asking itself how is it
going to shape our industry in fact it's
but there will be changes other
industries have been changed and the
water industry will probably be also
changed by it so yeah Megan are you
seeing any interesting frontier areas of
research for machine learning artificial
intelligence and water yes so I think
that there's actually lots of
applications across many different
scales there are applications in water
resource management understanding where
there's water supply using side
data to understand things about snow
cover and when we expect to see peak
flows etc there's applications at the
process level ensuring that your
processes are running at their most
efficient possible sort of standards and
and energy efficiency particularly when
that comes to operating these systems
dynamically either to respond to
variable water quality or changes in the
required treatment volume particularly
if you did want a pair of this with
intermittent energy sources and then I
think there's also applications in
machine learning and and advanced
computational tools in terms of actually
designing the materials that are going
into water treatment processes so
there's a number of examples here at
Carnegie Mellon of people who are doing
materials based research that's
leveraging computational tools both to
predict material properties but also to
optimize those properties pinky where is
sort of machine learning and artificial
intelligence land in the product and
technology roadmap for your company well
I think just taking a step back the you
know we're still one of the things we
struggle with every day is the issues of
cybersecurity Zoar clients face and
willingness to share data and there's a
paradigm shift needed in you know the
industrial water technology world lives
in a reactive alarm based culture and we
have to move to sensing and predictive
diagnostics so before we can move to
optimization and Prevention and and I
think that shift along with the cyber
security challenges will you know open
up a huge frontier the the opportunity
is is vast to drive performance but you
know we need more cost-effective sensing
technology and it has to be sensing the
things we need today the types of things
we put in our systems aren't what we
need to sense so there there's a lot of
change needed at that basic level and
CMU's at the forefront of integration
of automation across different fields
whether it be chemical engineering
material science and computer
engineering and I think they're very
well positioned okay we're coming up on
the end of our time so I want to ask one
final question for each of you and turn
it back towards the individual we've
talked a lot about water and energy
infrastructures but ultimately water and
water use comes down to people so I'm
curious Venki for you and your family
and the future as we continue in a world
where we have more climate uncertainty
where we continue in a world where water
resources may be more and more precious
what changes do you think individuals
should think about in terms of their
personal water use and how they interact
with the world of water well my wife
reminds me about how much water I use in
my shower every day I tell her well we
we save water around the world every day
she says doesn't matter and I think
thinking is important as far as what we
do personally because every I think
every drop counts Megan what do you
think for the personal use in the future
I think we need to remember that a very
large fraction somewhere between 70 or
so percent of our water is actually used
in agricultural sector so some of the
the most effective ways that you can
personally change our water footprint is
to change your food foot food footprints
nope or hamburgers Oh Peter
okay okay what do you what lessons do
you take both and maybe some lessons
you've seen from other countries that
have dealt with water scarcity more than
States no I think first on a personal
level I think I have three daughters I
think education is very important I
think we need to educate our young
children very early on you know water
what is water
you know bacteria what is bacteria you
know so they are not afraid of bacteria
but I think it's a education education
is very important now what there is
worldwide water there's a no border you
know evaporation and then cloud so so I
think water is also a good place to to
exchange between countries between
people we have the same problems and
it's a ground that is a bit more neutral
so I think it's a fantastic place about
partnerships hmm and things like that so
I think water is so maybe even the most
contentious places on earth right now we
can all agree to one thing and that is
water is an important part of our future
all right with that everybody think I
want to thank our panelists again and
thank the audience for these fabulous
questions and we look forward to the
rest of the day thank you everybody
[Applause]